nev campbell is letting everybody in on
a scary incident that took place when
she was working on a set here in canada
yeah appearing on the kelly clarkson
show never revealed she was once chased
and attacked by a bear when she was just
17.
i was
yeah playing this role where she's one
with the animals and
once i run
and there was there was a scene where
i'm supposed to be getting chased by a
bear the only animal i'm not one within
the movie um
and they just they brought this bear on
set and they said you know dip your hand
in hot no they first gave me a big
bottle of coke to feed it
and i thought coca-cola yeah coca-cola
so now this is like a bear on a sugar
rush and then they said and i'm 17 so
i'm really dumb and they give me they
say dip your hand in honey and just run
and when you get to the tree over there
turn around and stick your hand out and
feed the bear and i of course wanting to
please everyone was like okay
so and you're thinking obviously i'm in
a safe environment someone has done this
before me yeah yeah
and i dip my hand in honey and i run to
this rock or this tree they tell me to
go to and i turn around and i put my
hand out and the bear is not slowing
down and he's not coming from my hand
and he grabs me by the leg and he pulls
me through the forest and my mother
happens to be visiting set so she's
screaming the whole crew's frozen
because no one can believe what's
happening and it's and all i could all i
could think to say was he's biting me
like it wasn't obvious
nobody knows he's fighting me
through the force and then finally the
the bear wrangler starts just throwing
rocks at the bear to get it off me and
it finally gets pissed off and turns
around and goes after him and i run i go
up a rock
what in the hell
did i just listen to
i don't need more details i don't know
what kind of budget they had on this set
but this sounds like stuff that should
not happen on a movie set at all put
your hand in honey and let the bear
chase you
that's the plan
okay
okay i just it's it's a miracle she
survived all those scream movies you're
going to go towards the bear
with honey on your hand
okay what i don't and you would think
make sense and at that point you start
thinking okay like even when you're
being dragged around maybe you have one
thought and maybe that one thought is
okay somebody saved me and yes there's
people here that know what to do in a
situation like this right so you maybe
for one second hope for the best and
then when you see the guy in charge of
the bear the bear trainer his thought
was to just start throwing rocks at the
bear like he had nothing else like there
was no other preparation for what if
this bear goes crazy and eats a 17 year
old like that's it that's the plan throw
rocks
how are you wrangling the bear with
rocks i don't know man
you can't do that stuff on movie sets
anymore there's no way
i'm so mad it's canadian i'm like oh
does it have to be canadian but it's
it's come on how that's the most
canadian thing i've ever heard that may
be the most canadian story i've ever
heard in my life